pas pressé raid et warda pas c'est ça
superbe
qui
[Musique]
j'ai toujours
justement on vient d'écouter la
fédération me demande c'est quoi vous la
voiture sont préférés de boisement de
vous c'était take that le slow back for
good
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi bon alliage quoi laquelle
oui vous gérez
quoi
[Musique]
après ses déboires tapas c'est ça
m
plus
de toi
maxime par le boys band le plus
emblématique c'est les to be free avec
partir un jour évidemment
[Musique]
même dans ses chansons il nous met un
truc convient d'écouter s'étaient tous
mes frais or not to be
ah oui c'est vrai ferrand voilà ça jls
quelqu'un capable de redonner le nom de
toute l'espagne à aa par me jean alesi
qui thierry ville et k way malmy mails
si bien son rival déry commune les
dinosaures us
un groupe de dinosaures qui sévissait en
l'occurrence et les m5
[Musique]
entamée
c'est gbagbo
et
ouais
un groupe tout en guitares et en
poitrail viril sur cette loi
les gipsy kings
[Rires]
mais jusque là aucune fille au monde
[Musique]
thio mots mes plus belles dents c'est
pour isabelle est plus belle que toi
pour moi je vise à abroger une rave
party
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]